we're facing an army of Romans Vikings
and pirates did you know what today is
the name legends oopsies legends of
tomorrow season finale this Monday at
8:00 7:00 central on the CW hey
everybody it's Charlie we got the
legends of tomorrow finale next week
malice is free and we got a whole bunch
of characters coming back and I'll
address what's happening with next
season because the show was renewed for
season four just like all the other DC
TV shows so if you are finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all the DC videos I'll do a new
flash ring for pretty much all the DC
videos next week the flash is back next
week so I'm assuming that wally west
will go back to the flash before the
finale even though there's several more
episodes left left really hard when
wally kept reminding them about
flashpoint Barry went back to save his
mother
it created flashpoint it was the worst
thing ever I saw what happened with
Barry Allen when he went back and
stopped his mother's murder a little
thing called flashpoint
[Applause]
and they just confirmed that sarah is
going to get star in the arrow finale
along with Tommy so obviously there's a
lot of arrow stuff we need to talk about
but you kind of see in this past week's
episode episode 17 how they were dealing
with her relationship with damian
darhk-- and how she really wants to kill
him but she can't because of what
they're doing right now but she wants
justice for Laurel her arc is really
going to culminate with her appearance
on arrow so they're gonna have their
birds of prey style episode because you
have three different versions of the
Black Canary and I count earth to Laurel
even though she's black siren she's like
an evil version to the Black Canary they
have something of a redemptive arc for
her so they're gonna address that
through Sara's character because Sara is
one of the only characters that hasn't
met her evil sister from earth-2
speaking of Sara if you guys didn't see
caity lotz posted that funny music video
on her Twitter of them doing Will
Smith's wild wild west Kimberley post
the whole video here for copyright
reasons copyright on YouTube big problem
music copyright on YouTube is even worse
it's a bit of a nightmare but the thing
about this past week's episode like it's
crazy legends has done a really good job
of plotting the season out like there
are a couple moments that just didn't
work for me just like way too cheesy
like on paper the idea of an Obama
episode sounds like a lot of fun but
make America grot again was kind of like
the tipping point like you expect them
to have really cheesy lines like that in
there but they took it a little too far
like Sarah going to Obama for advice
that also sounds like a really funny
idea but only if you do that once per
episode and there were just several
moments like that during the episode so
I feel like even though legends of
tomorrow bills itself as the ridiculous
air over show sometimes is a little too
ridiculous I was on board for the Lord
of the Rings twist I was like okay we'll
accept the fact that heatwave just
happens to be watching Lord of the Rings
the same week that they're gonna have
John Noble himself guest star on the
show will just accept that ridiculous
setup and I do like when they actually
had the actor come on like out of his
trailer as if he were on the set of Lord
of the Rings can you believe that like
he was making fun of the dialogue that
Ray had written for him
this is crap I could hear the legends
writers room just laughing around the
table writing some of this dialogue like
when Nobel was saying man this is
talking you can't change the dialogue
and raise like no no no we're gonna do
this you're you're she's a new character
that they wanted to beef up the female
presence in the film he can't do that my
talk you'd go to the ring the weirdest
thing about the episode to me is how
they're changing the timeline for amaya
so this is obviously a big comic book
moment it's part of vixens origin story
but that's the present-day vixen who's
in Detroit remember the actress had to
leave the show before she was going to
become a main character so that's why
they cast this version of vixen as part
of the Justice Society storyline
originally it was going to be the vixen
that had crossed over onto arrow from
present-day but with the way the show
treats timeline changes I don't know if
they're gonna allow this to stick
because like in the comics a Maya's
daughter never became a totem bear the
village was destroyed and it became this
big driving arc for the young version of
the character if they do make it stick I
think it'll probably be fine I don't
think there's that many like old-school
hardcore vixen comic-book fans that
would be like super upset and are
watching this show the vixen character
is kind of like a c-list character when
you change things about their character
as long as it makes sense for what
they're doing I think it's okay
like there are still people that are a
little upset about mr. terrific because
he was a slightly bigger character even
though he is still kind of a c-list
character but that's why they made him
Curtis Holt not Michael Holt because
Michael Holt is the comic book mr.
terrific all the actors performances
across the board were great I'm not a
big fan of Ray Palmer's character
sometimes he just flat-out annoying and
there were a lot of scenes like that for
him in this episode just like oh god
this is just too much
but like 99% of all the performances
were great but like you see all of
damian darhk-- scenes how much he cares
about saving his daughter
I think moments like that in this whole
arc are the reason why Neal McDonough
agreed to come back and be a character
on the show because he could go on any
other big Network show and earn more
money but I think that they were like
okay no no we're gonna give you kind of
a redemptive arc you're still an evil
character but he really cares about his
daughter
why he's doing all these crazy things so
you kind of see some of the emotional
payoffs show themselves even though they
won't be achieved till the finale and
for some people like Sara with Laurel
that won't happen till the arrow finale
in a couple more weeks but just a
reminder that because they're in the
Wild West Jonah Hex is coming back for
the finale and Constantine because
Constantine is gonna be a season four
series regular on the Waverider I don't
know if they're gonna cycle any more of
the characters other than Wally West I'm
not expecting anyone to leave but it's
totally possible we won't get a better
idea of that till we actually see the
finale next week so be sure and check it
out don't forget Flash's back next week
arrows back next week arrows gonna be
pretty crazy for the rest of the season
too so if you jumped off that I would
recommend you get back on I'm kind of
trying to combine a couple different
videos with this so I know I didn't do
my regular top ten but obviously there
were a bunch of Easter eggs like when
rip tells Ava that she's 12 that's a big
Doctor Who joke 11 was Rory's doctor
Arthur Darvill so when he says that 11
died before is like saying that his
doctor died when Roary left the show I'm
not sure why they didn't call her the
thirteenth model because the thirteenth
Doctor is the new female doctor that
would have made more sense maybe they
didn't want to be too on-the-nose with
it the actual title of the finale is the
good the bad and the cuddly obviously a
reference to the good the bad and the
ugly I don't know if that's gonna have
something to do with the Bebo or there's
gonna be some funny twist legends in
general is just really ridiculous so
usually they're big twists wind up being
ridiculous I don't think that malice is
going to destroy all of time the entire
air over so they're gonna defeat him
somehow
but in the way that they take the piss
out of the villains like last season
with the reverse-flash he had the spear
of destiny in an army of other reverse
flashes but they still yanked the rug
out from under him it sounds like the
same thing will happen with Mallis like
they have the six totems
even though damian darhk-- has got off
the rails so let me know how you think
they're gonna do that Tomales is
character and I understand you know like
there are certain realities of making a
television show there's only so much
that you can cross over with other shows
but I will be a little upset if Wally
goes back to the flash this season
before the finale and doesn't reference
any of the flashpoint timeline changes
that the legends were making themselves
like oh I tried to tell him Barry but
they didn't want to listen there was a
giant time demon he threatened
destroy everything he was like tense
avatars put together which is exactly
why I think that the legends finale will
have some ridiculous
twist because they're hyping up malice
so much so whereas avatar was a
speedster that was arguably more
powerful than Barry he could do a lot of
damage that speedsters themselves can do
because he could travel through the
Speed Force and he was more powerful
than the other flashes so he could kill
them but the idea of the Mallis arc is
that it's a big parody of infinity war
like you have the six totems the six
infinity gems Thanos assembles the
Infinity Gauntlet controls all of
reality changes whatever he wants Mullis
has control over all of reality changes
whatever he wants you don't do a parody
like that without having some big funny
twist and then making fun of it later on
other TV shows where similar characters
tried to do the same thing so just brace
yourself for Infinity Ward jokes in the
legends finale although I don't think
they're gonna be too on-the-nose like I
think they've already kind of done that
with the idea of the six totems but let
me know in the comments what did you
think of the episode and what's gonna
happen later tonight is because Legion
episode 1 is happening I'll do an
episode 1 video that won't post til
tomorrow there will be a new Deadpool
trailer that I'll post later tonight
where you wait for everything click here
for my flash season 5 video and click
here for brand new infinity war thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight